Howard Stern's long career has been
extremely well documented after all
the guy's spent countless hours talking
about his life on the radio for 40 years
but as it turns out there are still a
few things even the greatest shock jock
of all time doesn't like talking about
here's the untold truth of Howard Stern
weird Howard in 1982 Stern Robin Quivers
and producer Fred Norris were just
starting to pop on the radio in
Washington DC so maybe that's why Stern
recorded 50 ways to rank your mother an
album full of Weird Al style song
parodies which is not his finest moment
which is saying a lot
the title track is a parody of Paul
Simon's 50 ways to leave your lover and
other songs include I shot Ron Reagan
[Music]
and oh-oh-oh-oh-oh J baby you can rent a
car which is about a Jay Simpson still
over a decade before his murder trial
being a Hertz a spokesman
there's also comedy bits like a fake ad
for an album by Neil Young's cat and a
filthy take on Leave It to Beaver called
unclean beaver which is what the album
was retitled for its reissue in 1994
Stern versus Leno there doesn't seem to
be much love lost between Howard Stern
and Jay Leno these days just a mere
mention of Jay Leno's name makes me want
to vomit I don't like this guy I don't
disguise it and probably what area to
irritates me the most is people in show
business are afraid to say how much they
dislike Jay Leno but I am NOT in 2012 he
called Leno a spineless maggot which
almost cost him his gig on America's Got
Talent
but back in the early 90s the two seem
to have had something resembling a
cordial relationship Stern made a few
highly rated appearances on Jay Leno's
Tonight Show wanting to raise the stakes
for his appearance in 1995 the shock
jock brought to bikini clad porn stars
Nicki Tyler and Janine Lindemulder
onstage with them he staged the tonight
show's first lesbian kiss and urged Leno
to spank one of the women has there ever
been a spanking done would you like a
little event Leno was visibly
uncomfortable for the segment and
eventually walked off the show which was
edited out of the later broadcast after
Stern's 2000 appearance on Leno their
relationship seemed to you permanently
sour I work for NBC television now and
I'm not speaking to Jay Leno they asked
me to go on the show I go no he did date
wrong don't mess with Texas days after
singer Selena was murdered the Howard
Stern Show played some of her music with
gunfire in the background after that
Stern had some pretty nasty things to
say about her music and throwing some
insults of Hispanic people for good
measure benefit one of the worst paint
the music they really do Alvin and the
Chipmunks head north all the comments so
incensed Loy Cano a justice of the peace
and hauling in Texas that he issued a
warrant for Stern's arrest citing
disorderly conduct technically police
could have arrested Stern if he set foot
in Texas during that time but then still
probably like compared to what Selena
fans would have done
pushed his suicide TV sitcom Diff'rent
Strokes made dana plato a child star in
the 80s most people remember the show is
a launching pad for Plato's co-star Gary
Coleman but the popular sitcom made the
whole cast famous but like fellow
strokes vet Todd bridges Plato fell on
hard times after Diff'rent Strokes ended
and battled substance abuse on May 7
1999 Plato appeared on the Howard Stern
Show to discuss her troubled life drug
use poverty and run-ins with the law but
claimed to be sober for ten years at
that point
have you been in psychotherapy have you
been on any medication or the longest
time really oh it's over a decade now no
kidding no joke when callers accused her
of sounding high she offered to take a
drug test to prove it I just don't - I
did attend my charity with you
I'm clean you doing drug producer Gary
Dell'Abate snipped a few hair samples
from her with the intention of sending
them to the lab Stern later said that
after the show the former child star
begged to have the hair samples back
because she didn't want them tested the
following day Plato visited her mother
and Moore Oklahoma for Mother's Day
while there she overdosed in the
painkiller lortab and the muscle
relaxant soma police later ruled her
death a suicide co-worker feuds from
Bugs Bunny and Space Jam 2 Futurama stri
voiceover superstar Billy West is an
industry legend shut up and take my
money he also provided voices for the
Howard Stern Show back in 1989 doing
impersonations of celebs like Johnny
Carson Johnnie Cochran and Lucille Ball
Lucy I just want to get home you keep
calling me we're just so through in 1991
West also started working on
Nickelodeon's new animated series the
Renton Stimpy show the show's creator
John Crisco Lucy was fired by the
network in 1992 and he wanted West to
walk away too but he refused
in 1995 Stern surprised West by bringing
Chris felluci on the show
it got uncomfortable when you got fired
Billy stayed with the cartoon it took
over your voice did you really expect
Billy to leave
uh yeah you did you did expect Billy to
leave no he told me it was going down at
same here west left the show after
failed contract negotiations with
Stearns then employer infinity
broadcasting in 2009 West appeared on a
Sirius XM show Jackie's joke Hunt hosted
by fellow former stern staffer Jackie
Martling
when asked if he'd go back on stern show
West said he wouldn't and might read a
book about why he left meanwhile John
Melendez started as a Howard Stern Show
intern in 1988 the story goes that Stern
won and Melendez hired because of a
stutter which led to the nickname
stuttering John eventually Stern sent
Melendez to red carpets to ask
celebrities uncomfortable and
confrontational questions the recurring
bit turned into a fan favourite and
stuttering John became a full-time
employee I think you're a schmuck
that is until 2004 when he left the
Howard Stern Show to become an announcer
slash on-air personality at the Tonight
Show
it's a Tonight Show with Jay Lowe John
shut up will ya you got the job four
years later Melendez went on the Adam
Carolla Show and talked about how Stern
never paid him fairly he also said that
Stern didn't like his employees taking
on outside gigs to make ends meet I love
Howard and all but my biggest beef has
always been in that show that you know
they just don't take care of people
financially following that interview
Stern released a half-hour rant on his
Sirius XM show calling Melendez an
ungrateful and talentless hack Stern
even went as far as to say that he no
longer wanted his then fiancee Beth
Ostrosky being friends with John's wife
in the summer of 2016 though stuttering
John announced on his podcast that he
and Stern have finally reconciled
finally for almost ten years
comedian Artie Lange was Stern's
sidekick when Jackie Martling left and
the pairing seemed perfect unfortunately
Lange's long documented problem with
addiction proved to be too much and in
December 2009 he was asked to take time
off weeks later Lange attempted suicide
after his rehabilitation stirring
thought at best he didn't return in an
interview from June 2016 Leng stated
that Stern continued to be there for him
through many of his toughest years but
they don't speak any longer
Lange has attempted calling stern
numerous times with no response
I call them four times probably three or
four times I left voicemails and he
but we're back why leg thinks it stems
from the moment when Stern asked him if
he thought Stern look like a pelican and
Lange said yes Lange were called on the
enough about me podcast what he said you
think I look like a pelican and I said
yes there was no going back considering
everything Stern said and done over the
decades all it took to hurt his feelings
was being compared to a pelican how are
you and I have a lot in common we both
we thought I like to take a four-hour
dump every morning though thanks for
watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos at the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know what Howard Stern moment shock to
you the most